IN MOMENTS, VERDEAN WHITE,
JOINING US NOW, STEVIE WONDER.
STEVIE, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
SORRY FOR THE LOSS OF YOUR
FRIEND.
WHEN YOU HEARD THE NEWS THIS
MORNING, WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR
MIND?
>> WELL, IT IS A HEART BREAK.
A SHOCK.
I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE, IN
THIS JOURNEY OF MUSIC, WE AS
ARTISTS CREATE A REFLECTION OF
SOCIETY AND REFLECT REALLY THE
PEOPLE THAT REALLY WANTED TO SEE
A BETTER WORLD, UNITY OF PEOPLE,
ALL THOSE THINGS, AS MUSIC WILL
CONTINUE TO DO FOR THOSE OF US
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO
IT.
IT IS HEART BREAK TO LOSE A
MEMBER OF THAT ARMY OF LOVE.
>> PRINCE TALKING ABOUT YOU ON
LARRY KING, SAYING YOU WERE A
ROLE MODEL AND INSPIRATION FOR
HIM WHEN IT CAME TO PLAYING HIS
OWN INSTRUMENTS.
HOW DOES HE INSPIRE YOU?
>> WELL, HE WAS A GREAT
MUSICIAN.
HE LOVED MUSIC, LOVED PLAYING
HIS INSTRUMENT.
THE TIMES WE DID JAM TOGETHER
WERE AMAZING.
ALL OF THE VARIOUS PEOPLE HE
WOULD BRING TOGETHER.
MOSTLY HE BROUGHT ALL THE
VARIOUS CULTURES TOGETHER.
HE COULD PLAY CLASSICAL MUSIC IF
HE WANTED TO, JAZZ IF HE WANTED
TO, COUNTRY IF HE WANTED TO,
PLAYED ROCK, YOU KNOW, HE PLAYED
BLUES.
HE PLAYED POP.
EVERYTHING.
JUST A GREAT MUSICIAN.
AND VERY COGNIZANT OF WHAT HIS
RESPONSIBILITY WAS AS A MUSICIAN
AND HUMAN BEING.
>> TODAY I WAS WATCHING
RECORDING OF A CONCERT THAT YOU
DID IN PARIS BACK IN 2010.
YOU WERE PERFORMING
"SUPERSTITION."
PRINCE WAS ACCOMPANYING YOU ON
GUITAR.
HE WASN'T JUST A GREAT SONG
WRITER, HE WAS A STELLAR GUITAR
PLAYER, AND NOT JUST GUITAR, HE
PLAYED NEARLY ALL THE
INSTRUMENTS ON THE FIRST FIVE
ALBUMS.
I MEAN, THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> YEAH, IT'S AMAZING.
YOU KNOW, IT IS FUN TO DO THAT.
BASICALLY YOU'RE GOING INSIDE
YOURSELF AND YOU'RE REALLY
GIVING PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE PART
OF WHAT YOU FEEL.
IT IS WHAT YOUR SOUL IS SAYING,
THIS IS HOW I WANTED THIS TO BE
PLAYED.
FORTUNATELY I CAN PLAY IT AND
EXPRESS MYSELF, LIKE AN ARTIST
PAINTING A PICTURE.
SO HE WAS A GREAT ARTIST, OF
PICTURE, SOUND, PICTURE AND
MUSIC.
THIS IS AN AMAZING DAY AS WE SEE
SO MANY THINGS HAPPENING, THE
HEARTBREAK TO SEE THIS MAN WHO
WAS SO TALENTED BE TAKEN AWAY
FROM US.
BUT I KNOW THAT THE ALMIGHTY GOD
HAS FAR GREATER THINGS FOR HIM
TO DO ETERNALLY.
I JUST HOPE WE CELEBRATE HIS
MUSIC, CELEBRATE HIS PURPOSE
THAT HE FULFILLED.
>> WITH THAT IDEA OF CELEBRATING
HIS MUSIC, YOU AND PRINCE SANG
TOGETHER AT THE WHITE HOUSE LAST
YEAR.
IS THERE A FAVORITE SONG OF
YOURS?
IS THERE SOMETHING, I THINK
YOU'RE NEAR A PIANO.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT COMES TO
YOUR HEART, THAT COMES TO YOUR
HEAD IN TERMS OF MUSIC WHEN YOU
THINK OF HIM?
>> YOU KNOW, I LOVE PURPLE RAIN,
THE WHOLE ALBUM WAS IN CREDIBLE,
BUT I LOVE THE STUFF HE DID.
THE SONG THAT -- I LIKE THE
WHOLE ALBUM.
I LIKE -- PEOPLE SAID EARLIER
TODAY ON CNN, SOMEONE THAT SAID
HE WAS ABLE TO MIX THE BLESSING
OF LIFE OF GOD AND YET, YOU
KNOW, THE MARRIAGE OF SEX AND
PASSION.
SO THAT'S VERY, VERY TRUE.
HE HAD FUN DOING IT.
IT IS RARE FOR ME THAT I CAN
FEEL WITH EVERY SINGLE BREATH
HOW HE JUST PASSIONATELY LOVED
MUSIC.
LIKE WHEN MUSICIANS CAN JAM,
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE IT IN THE
WHOLE WORLD.
IT IS LIKE WHEN BALL PLAYERS ARE
PLAYING, THEY'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THE GAME, IT IS THE SAME THING
WITH US AS MUSICIANS TO BE ABLE
TO SAY OKAY, YOU CAN DO THAT,
WATCH ME DO THIS, YOU CAN DO
THAT, I'M DO THAT.
IT IS JUST A LOT OF FUN.
HE WAS INCREDIBLE WITH THAT.
>> IS THERE, I DON'T WANT TO PUT
YOU ON THE SPOT.
IS THERE ANY SONG YOU WANT TO
SING A LITTLE OF, PLAY A LITTLE
OF?
AGAIN, I DON'T WANT TO PUT YOU
ON THE SPOT IF YOU'RE NOT UP FOR
IT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK I WOULD PROBABLY
BREAKDOWN IF I DO A SONG RIGHT
NOW, BUT YOU KNOW, HE WAS
INCREDIBLE.
I'M JUST GLAD I WAS ABLE TO SAY
TO HIM I LOVE YOU THE LAST TIME
I SAW HIM.
>> AND HE WROTE A LOT OF SONGS
FOR OTHER ARTISTS OVER THE
YEARS, AND HE WAS ALSO A
PHILANTHROPIST, DONATING
INSTRUMENTS FOR YOUNG MUSICIANS,
CONCERNED ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES.
HE DID A LOT OF THINGS FOR
CHARITY AND DIDN'T NECESSARILY
GET HIS NAME ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT.
DID A LOT OF THINGS ANONYMOUSLY.
>> WELL, I THINK HIS SPIRITUAL
COMMITMENT WAS FAR BIGGER THAN
HIM HAVING TO SAY HE DID THIS
AND HE DID THAT.
HIS COMMITMENT WAS IN THE ACTION
OF WHAT HE DID, NOT WITH THE
SATISFACTION OF LETTING PEOPLE
KNOW THAT HE DID IT.
>> HOW DO YOU, I DON'T KNOW IF I
SHOULD EVEN ASK THIS QUESTION,
BECAUSE IT IS MAYBE TOO SOON TO
FIGURE THIS OUT, CERTAINLY WE'LL
ALWAYS HAVE THE MUSIC, BUT HOW
DO YOU HOPE PEOPLE REMEMBER HIM?
>> JUST A GREAT MUSICIAN, A
GREAT PRODUCER, GREAT SONG
WRITER.
SOMEONE THAT ALLOWED HIMSELF TO
BE HIMSELF AND ENCOURAGED OTHERS
TO BE THEMSELVES.
HE WAS VERY FREE AND TO DO WHAT
HE DID WITHOUT FEAR WAS A
WONDERFUL THING BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS GREAT, IT IS ALWAYS GREAT
WHEN WE DON'T ALLOW FEAR TO PUT
OUR DREAMS TO SLEEP, AND HE
DIDN'T.
>> STEVIE WONDER, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
AGAIN, I'M SORRY WE'RE TALKING
UNDER T